now to an update on a heartbreaking
story of animal abuse we brought you
earlier this week Althea the Pitbull who
was found to Skin and Bones is making
some improvements tonight Victoria Saha
brings us the latest
it sounds like Althea has something to
say as she takes baby steps towards her
recovery the seven-year-old's pit bull
has been transferred to the Spencer
Springs Animal Hospital where she is now
walking you can really see how thin she
is when she stands up a huge difference
from when we first saw her at the
veterinary Critical Care Center just a
few days ago where she was too weak to
stand up on her own she is still very
thin but she is up to 31 Pounds so we
are very very excited about that you're
hearing Tina Hayes voice from Vegas Pet
Rescue project as she gives us an update
on Althea Althea was found earlier this
month on the street barely 23 pounds and
taken to the animal foundation where
Vegas Pet Rescue project took her under
their care we're just beside herself
that people
it was clear Althea was neglected and
didn't have food for a while chances of
Althea surviving were slim as a dog her
size and age should be around 60 to 70
pounds but with her making improvements
she's showing us she isn't letting her
abusers win
[Music]
Victoria Saha 8 news now Althea is
getting plenty of IV fluids and several
small meals a day so she can gain weight
slowly